she is in Paris as Iraq's prime minister
of Science and economic agreement with
France it aims to increase cooperation
in energy and public transportation
Muhammad Sudani has described it as a
valuable partnership that will reform
and develop his country
it's the first long-term strategic
agreement to be sealed by an Iraqi
government at the Elysee Palace a
partnership with France opens the door
to Europe it includes investment in oil
and gas clean energy and a tramline
project
but back home anger soaring as the local
currency depreciates against the US
dollar it is reportedly a result of
money laundering by Iraqi Banks and the
smuggling of dollars across the border
two countries including Iran many blame
institutional corruption
the Prime Minister hasn't delivered on
his promises now we are hungry because
it is failure and he can't even confront
Parliament with it if he's unable to
solve matter he should step down in a
bid to contain public anger Sudani has
sacked the Central Bank governor
when he took office in October the Prime
Minister promised to fight corruption
and his administration has been praised
for exposing the embezzlement of
billions of dollars but it's also been
accused of nepotism
this government is basically serving
political interests rather than serving
the people asak many officials in
replacement with his allies included
unqualified and corrupt officials that
means a prime minister is manipulated by
certain political parties and the people
reject this
degrees here in mid-January after months
of Silence supporters of prominent Shia
leader gathered in Baghdad to denounce
State corruption and call for economic
reforms Sudani is also trying to balance
Iraqi foreign policy by taking a less
confrontational approach towards
Washington to strengthen his position
and gain international support Sudani is
hoping to keep up on the momentum of
cooperation with Western powers
but that could be challenging if his
iran-backed allies continue to reject
America's presence in Iraq and if talks
to revive the nuclear deal remain
deadlocked
Mahmoud Abdullah al-jazeerah